wenn deine Pastagerichte so aussehen und
nicht so wunderschön cremig wie dieses
hier dann kann ich dir genau verraten
woran das ganze liegt ich habe zwei
Töpfe und zwei Pfannen und alle zut an
die man für Spaghetti alio olio braucht
mit einem kleinen aber feinen
Unterschied hier drüben haben wir
Spaghetti al bronzo die sehr sehr schön
rau sind und hier Handels übliche
Spaghetti wie man sie z.B von Barilla
bekommt durch die raue Oberfläche wird
nämlich Stärke ins Nudelwasser abgegeben
sass eine Bindung entstehen kann wir
kochen beide pastas 2 Minuten unter al
dente jetzt gebe ich in beide Pfannen
Olivenöl und die stengngel von der
Petersilie außerdem einiges te
Knoblauchzehe so aromatisieren wir jetzt
das Öl in beiden Pfannen jetzt nehme ich
alles raus und jetzt können wir auch
Chili ins Öl geben die Nudeln sind fast
fertig das heißt wir können Sie in die
Pfanne geben und mit der Emulsion
beginnen direkt eine ordentliche Kelle
Nudelwasser dazu und das gleiche machen
wir auch auf der anderen Seite so gießen
wir jetzt kontinuierlich Nudelwasser
nach bis die Nudeln perfekt gekocht sind
die Nudeln kochen ich gebe ein bisschen
frischen knoblauuchf dazu bisschen
Petersilie und einen letzten Schluck
Nudelwasser und fertig sind die beiden
aliool pastas ab auf den Teller